hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar thinking outside of the box use
of hybrid PCR and culture approach for
identification of bacterial
gastrointestinal pathogens presented by
dr. Aaron Michael Vania director of
clinical microbiology North Shore
University Health System my name is
Christy Jewell and I'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by laberd's and brought to you
by BD for more information on our
sponsor please visit BD calm
now before we get started I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation you thought ask a question
box to let us know you're experiencing a
problem this presentation is educational
and the software's continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
and now present today's speaker dr.
Aaron Mikkel vania director of clinical
microbiology Northshore University
Health System for a complete biography
on our speaker please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
dr. Michael mania you may now begin your
presentation
thank you crispy for that warm
introduction and I'm very excited to
talk to you all today about thinking
outside the box use of hybrid PCR and
culture which is something that we've
been working on in my micro laboratory
so I want to first thank BD for
graciously asking me to give this
webinar and my additional disclosures
are posted below so what I'm going to
talk about today is I'm going to start
with traditional molecular and molecular
identification of gastrointestinal
pathogens just so we're all on the same
page then I'm going to talk about the
limits limitations and benefits of
molecular GI pathogen detection and
finally the project that I'm excited to
show you that we've been working on in
my lab which is use of a hybrid plus PCR
Plus culture method of detecting
gastrointestinal bacterial pathogens so
for traditional methods you can you know
all you probably know the stool culture
and you can see here all the different
things that you might need to identify
different enteric pathogens you've got
all the different media types that might
be set up biochemical testing
agglutination testing and this is a lot
of work for the technologists and it's
also takes a long time which is
something that we can definitely improve
upon so as you've seen their stool
culture is one of the most time
intensive tests of all the different
culture types we perform in the
microbiology laboratory and to get an
identification it is going to take a few
days to grow the bacteria then because
these are very mixed stool cultures you
have to isolate it away isolate the
pathogen away from the other fecal flora
on perform biochemical testing it can
take from two to five days to get that
result so I definitely think there are
ways to optimize this and molecular
testing is there to help us out so this
is really a lot less hands-on time for
the technologist
it also benefits patients and clinicians
by providing a faster turnaround time
and by having that result earlier they
are able to either prescribe antibiotics
if needed if they had initially given
antibiotics for suspicion of a bacterial
infection they could discontinue them at
that time if the result was negative and
also this can have public health
implications once you know what pathogen
you have you can definitely take steps
to prevent contact prevent spreading
that organism from the patient to other
contacts in the family
there are many fda-approved molecular
platforms for gastrointestinal pathogen
testing and you can see them listed here
I'm really when you're looking at what
you might want to bring into your
laboratory there's a lot of different
things you need to consider one is what
is your specimen volume do you need
something that can accommodate a larger
testing volume or is a small one at a
time method a an approach that would
work for your lab you need to look at
how long it will take to run the test
and what targets are on the panel
because different panels have many many
different configurations of targets and
you just need to pick the ones that are
right for your patient population
now that we know what's available for
molecular testing for GI pathogens I
want to talk a little bit about the
benefits limitations and considerations
that you need to keep in mind when
you're bringing these tests in-house and
when you're talking to clinicians about
the results of these tests
so one is increased sensitivity
molecular testing one of the benefits I
would say is it doesn't rely on a viable
organism for growth such as in
traditional culture it only relies upon
DNA of that organism being present so on
you know we find that using DNA testing
only these are very fastidious organisms
in the stool and so we find that often
they die in transport and we're not
picking them up one of the first studies
the luminix the luminix xTag deep GTP
which is gastrointestinal panel it was
found to be more sensitive than
traditional testing specifically for
Campylobacter Salmonella and c difficile
toxin and a few of the viruses and this
was a day from several years ago but
since then as the new FDA approved tests
have come onto the market all of them
have shown similar increases in
sensitivity compared to traditional
methods many of the times
Campylobacter and Shigella seem to be
two specific organisms in which that are
very fastidious and and can easily die
in transport and so those are our ones
that we see an increase in
another thing that was noticed when
molecular testing was implemented was
that there were a much higher number of
co-infections and previously suspected
or detected using traditional culture
methods
this is a study of the bio fire GI panel
in which they tested over 1,500
specimens and you can see you must
remember that the bio fire panel it
tests not just bacteria but bacteria
viruses and also some parasites and what
they found was that you can see half of
their specimens are just slightly less
than half their specimens at 46% where
we're negative and then about another
35% we're positive for one target and a
huge number were positive for two three
four or five and one for even six
different targets um so this can really
affect your interpretation and your
interpretation and also your clinicians
interpretation of the results because
they will definitely be calling you
asking you know why are there so many
code detections identified also remember
that these assays are qualitative not
quantitative so you won't know the
relative amount of DNA found for each
organism you'll just know that positive
or negative so it can be really hard to
know what might be a pathogen is this
patient caring on bacterial DNA of some
of these pathogens in their stool a
symptomatically were they getting over
1l 'no sand picking up another very very
hard to interpret some of these the
highest ko infection rate what happened
when we saw on we saw organisms that had
clustering discs so and also entró
pathogenic equal I or II Peck so those
were the two organisms that were most
likely to be found in a co infection
you
you
another thing that you will need to keep
in mind depending on what what panel
your pick picking to use for your lab
and and you might want to think about
this prior to picking a specific panel
is a lot of the multiplex assays have
new targets that were not previously
tested with routine stool culture
parasite OMP and viral detection and
this can be an area of great excitement
because a lot of times I don't think we
and I still think this is an area of
research where we don't always know
exactly the clinical significant of some
of these targets and we're learning a
lot about them now that we are doing
more routine testing but at the same
time it can cause a lot of frustration
or confusion to both the laboratory and
to the physicians when they have
patients that are positive for these
specific targets that and they don't
know what to do with the result they
don't know if it's clinically
significant if it should be ignored and
so just one thing to keep in mind again
as as you choose what kind of testing
you want to do in your lab
so when we think about bacterial
infection by culture we generally test
patients who have signs and symptoms of
diarrhea we find a pathogen and we
assume after treatment or F after a
passage of time a self-limited infection
will go away when you're looking for DNA
it's again an area research we know that
we are going to detect both live and
dead gastrointestinal pathogens because
we're just looking for the DNA doesn't
have to be viable organism we also know
that a symptomatic shedding is something
that happens so after the bacteria has
or virus I would say has you know after
it is no longer live or viable it can
persist or remnants of DNA can be in the
stool for weeks to months you know after
symptoms have resolved clinically and
the patient is doing is doing better so
we and we also know that the shedding is
more prolonged in immunocompromised
patient so it can sometimes influence
your results and how you think about
your results especially you know in
immunocompromised patients where you are
you are definitely in a setting where a
lot of things they're hospitalized a lot
of these patients and there are many
things including medication and and
other other clinical symptoms other
clinical entities that can cause them to
have diarrhea and so repeat testing may
make it seem like they constantly have
bacterial GI pathogens whereas it could
just be residual DNA that they are
harboring so bacterial shedding into the
stool is something that you also need to
keep in mind this happens because as we
mentioned that molecular tests are going
to detect DNA and so it will be
detecting both live and non-viable di
pathogens we know that a symptomatic
shedding of bacterial viral path
is something that can go on for weeks to
months after the patient has clinically
resolved their symptoms so they they are
all better and we were testing by stool
culture they would these patients would
have you know definitely seemed to have
recovered and clear their infections but
the DNA can still hold on or be present
for a long periods of time and we know
an immunocompromised patients it can be
even longer periods of shedding so we
need to make sure that we are when we're
interpreting results we keep that in
mind that it may not be an actual
infection it could just be the presence
of prolonged shedding and it can be
really hard for clinicians there's no
actual way to tell the difference how do
you determined active infection versus
shedding and the answer is for with
molecular testing you cannot tell if the
organism you're detecting is viable or
not
and Clostridium difficile which is you
know hot topic in laboratories
everywhere but is especially a reporting
to none Durham when we look at these
multiplex GI panels there are several
that contain that contain Clostridium
difficile as part of their target set
and you know both the lumen X X tag gtp
and the bio fire film array are are ones
that that do have the c-diff target both
the clustering toxin and B genes
um the eye panels can be ordered for
many reasons
you know you think your patient has
Salmonella Shigella you think they have
a parasite so there's so there's really
no age restriction that is placed on the
the GI panels but for children less than
two years of age but particularly those
one year of age the IDSA guidelines do
not recommend testing these patients
because they have a very high percentage
of CF colonization that is asymptomatic
so we do not want those patients to get
tested and treated and you cannot
separate clustering difficile from the
rest of the panel so it can be a bit of
a problem also stool consistency at
least in our lab we only test for a
clustering difícil on liquid stools and
we're very strict with our policy is to
lessen the chance that you will detect
asymptomatic colonization but
consistency cannot be assessed if the
stool is submitted in kerry blair medium
which is recommended as transport medium
for you know bacterial stool testing so
one way that you would not be able to
tell if your patient actually had
significant diarrhea or if their stool
with somewhat formed
so another thing to keep in mind when
you're bringing your molecular GI
testing in-house is that antimicrobial
susceptibility information is not going
to be provided by the assay because
again remember you're detecting DNA and
it's going to give you a detective not
detected result rather than having an I
slit as you would recover for bacterial
culture in our lab about 80 percent of
organisms we do attempt to recover
organisms if we have a positive
molecular result and about 80 percent of
the time we were able to do so but also
about 20 percent of the time that means
we are not able to provide that we like
to have the isolate around in case we
need to do susceptibility testing for
these patients and the other reason we
like to have the isolate is because we
work very closely with our Public Health
Department
so reportable pathogens are something
that micro labs have been sending into
their state Public Health Department
since the dawn of time but now that we
don't necessarily have the eye slits to
send who's responsibility does it end up
being to identify the organism is this a
clinical lab or is it the public health
laboratory and right now that's kind of
up in the air it's a lab by lab decision
maybe a state by state or a county by
county and some in some cases what is
required to be sent in to public health
and sometimes they will agree to let you
send in stool the stool specimen rather
than the isolate so they can try to
recover it there and and help their
Public Health Laboratory outbreak
investigations
so what happens of a passages detected
but you're not able to isolate in
culture so like I mentioned before this
is about the 20% of organisms that you
know we're just not able to isolate it
it is a somewhat interesting problem
that we have developed now that we've
increased our sensitivity of detection
but something you'll you'll need to
coordinate and keep in mind and
coordinate prior debris molecular
testing live in your house is in to your
labs how you're going to deal with these
situations because we definitely will
happen in molecular assays the downside
is you may not have an isolate some of
the time and there is a question about
who's going to be responsible for
isolating it but overall it can
molecular testing can really help
outbreak detection because like I
mentioned traditional cultures it just
takes a long time between when the
specimen is collected and when we're
putting out a result and that's when the
Public Health investigations really
start if there's an outbreak but by
rapidly identifying these organisms and
identifying patients that are positive
more quickly I think it can actually
really help investigations with their
timely reaching of patients to get out
to get information about where they've
been and what they've been eating and
identify you know identify may be a
possible source but then again if we if
we aren't able to get the isolates it it
is a little difficult because the
mainstay of Public Health investigations
is also gel electrophoresis and or maybe
whole genome sequencing if you're your
lab has moved that way but without a
bacterial isolate you won't have these
tools so in some ways molecular testing
can help outbreak investigations by
earlier recognition of outbreaks but
some ways it's really helpful to have
those isolates as well
and there are a few patient benefits to
having molecular GI assays so like I
said increased sensitivity so this is
for patients who may be maybe they had
improper storage of their specimen
during transport
maybe they have lower levels of organism
burning burden they will still be able
to know what pathogen caused their
diarrheal illness even though it's not
viable in culture through molecular
detection there's also the rapid
turnaround time which we talked about
which can aid in antibiotic optimization
or subspace cessation and then also it
might help patients to know what they
have so that if they definitively know
they have a bacterial pathogen GI
pathogen
they will then be I guess they will be
aided in you know understanding ways
that they can clean their homes and
clean you know clean their hands and
things like that so that they don't
spread this to other household members
and there's institutional benefit I
think is a little bit up in the air and
there's not been a lot of research in
this area but one early study I think it
was from 2014 was out of uk-based
Hospital and they looked at the ability
of molecular to both increase the
turnaround time for putting patients on
precautions and then a lot of the
patients they put on precautions for
dire diarrheal illnesses and just in
general and then they were able to
actually find the molecular testing
helped them by providing a rapid answer
taking patients off isolation
precautions saving them costs in the
different you know gowns and gloves and
you know all the things that go around
with patients on isolation so some small
cost saving to the hause the hospital
although I would definitely say most of
the benefit is on the patient's side
one thing I just wanted to mention very
quickly is reimbursement so this because
most of our stool specimens are coming
from outpatients we've found that
Medicare is pushing back on
reimbursement for broad syndromic
multiplex panels and this is this is one
thing that I followed very closely
because as you'll see in a moment when
we talk about my laboratories experience
with the GI pathogen testing most of our
patients samples are coming from
outpatients where and a lot of them are
Medicaid and private payer and whatever
happens with reimbursement is definitely
going to affect what we are able to
provide and offer to our patients in
testing in our lab testing so why so
what is reimbursement for GI panels look
like and why are we getting pushback by
by some of these companies they are
saying that coverage should be limited
to five pathogens listed here to make up
ninety to ninety-five percent of food
borne infections so they're willing to
provide reimbursement for those
organisms but they do not want to cover
viruses because they do lack treatment
so knowing you have a virus and you know
you're not going to treat it so
therefore you know why should we even
test to find out um and I would say
epidemiology is why you would want to
know
but epidemiology is there deeming not a
valid reason to test and you know
obviously a lot of microbiology
directors and physicians do not agree
with this reasoning but um but there it
is and then the other thing the is
clustering difficult testing because
that's not really appropriate to be to
be doing on every one we know about five
to ten percent of all people are
carriers asymptomatic carriers of
cluster iam difícil and so the molecular
detection cannot tell you a cost dream
difficile infection
versus colonization so when Clostridium
difficile on a panel they you know they
are they're saying panels cannot be an
unbundled and clustering difícil may not
be reasonable and necessary when ordered
so for these reasons we're watching the
reimbursement data very closely as I
mentioned because it's really going to
affect what we can offer in our lab if
we cannot get reimbursed so there's a so
this move to limit reimbursement as I
mentioned not only are there micro
directors and physicians who disagree
but also the American Society for
Microbiology sexist disease Society for
America IDSA and many other professional
organisms are are lobbying against this
and definitely letting people know that
these are very very useful tests a
current proposal that's been put out is
that from you you know competent hosts
or your your regular patient that comes
into their PCP or their primary care
physician office Medicaid will cover up
to five targets for if if Clostridium
difficile testing is indicated they will
cover up to eleven and if
immunocompromised patient patient needs
testing then they will cover greater
than twelve targets and and that kind of
makes sense for some of the esoteric
options that are on some of the panels
and it could make a big difference in
the immunocompromised patient it could
really be causing serious disease so
that's we're at right now keep it keep
an eye on that for sure and with that
I'm going to talk a little bit about
what we've done at our lab taking all
these factors but we definitely knew we
wanted to go to molecular detection of
GI pathogens which I'll talk to you talk
to you about in the section a second and
we took all the limitations and
considerations into account and our
patient population and this is kind of
what we've come up with so we'll
but unusual so so as I said like when we
decided we wanted to go towards
molecular testing we had to ask
ourselves a lot of different questions
about which test would work best for our
lab we want we looked at all the targets
that were available the sensitivity and
specificity of these results you know
how accurate are they for detecting
these organisms turnaround time for our
patient population or and as well as our
cost per test and then we looked at how
these would fit with our particular
patient populations is something every
hospital or every lab is going to need
to really do themselves as a assessment
because no one knows your patients
better than you so you have mainly an
adult or pediatric patient population
are they mostly impatient or do they
include a large number of outpatients as
well are they are these patients
primarily immuno compromised or immuno
competent and this will help you
determine which testing might work for
you
so one size is not at all many of these
panels this molecular GI panels have
very large number of targets I reported
on each specimen and the high number
targets often equals a very very high
cost so you can see here you know one
size not fit all no one essay is going
to be perfect for every lab
what is really best for patient care in
your patient population so you need
targets that are going to fit the needs
of your patients being tested those that
provide useful data that clinicians are
going to use to treat their patients and
avoiding targets they're going to
provide little clinical value or
confusion in your particular population
and then you need to think about cost
and as a laboratory in I never really
want to think about cost to be honest
it's my least favorite thing to consider
because I really look at what's best for
the patient and and I let administration
kind of you know deal with the cost
costing issues but I mean it it is
something that we have to consider that
also as a user of the healthcare system
cannot justify an incredibly high cost
you know relative to what what
information is being gathered from that
so a so for us we thought it would be
best you know if we could keep it makes
sense that for a lower cost for
otherwise healthy patients who need
information from just your basic target
so your basic bacterial targets that
seemed reasonable and then of course for
your immunocompromised patients we're
and complicated get patients that your
gastroenterologist are seeing that might
the value in a very broad number of
targets really is there so it can go
either way
you just have to fit it to the specific
patient a little bit about my hospital
so Northshore University Health System
is in the North suburbs of Chicago we
have four hospitals but we also have a
lot of testing from outpatient we have
about twenty immediate care facilities
in over a hundred different physician
offices for what that send us they're
testing our volume is here I think front
350 now thousands specimens per year
also
and is growing about 5% per year and we
are extremely lucky to have the BBC
strata laboratory automation system so
we were the first in the u.s. installed
in 2014
so historically our testing for GI
pathogen and I mean historically as in
last year we did bacterial culture any
time we were looking for bacterial
pathogens we have a clustering difícil
stand-alone pcr we had a sugar toxin
immunoassay over in parasite examination
we still do that to this day and then
for other things that we didn't see that
much in our in our population such as
interrogate or micros perineum we would
definitely send out to a reference lab
what was our impetus for change why
didn't you know that worked fine for
many many years why do we need to change
now and I will say it's because we I
noticed that we were getting a lot of
samples from our outpatient labs and the
transport conditions were horrific so I
just have a few examples here that I
collected you know you've got your nice
small and carry Blaire that's perfect
then you got stool and a cup and then
you've got stool and like a takeout
container and you know we've we've
gotten some other interesting specimen
containers as well when I dug into it I
found out that 85% of her stool
specimens are submitted by outpatients
and even if you present to the doctor
you go to the doctor with diarrhea it's
very unlikely even if you're having you
know ten bowel movements per day that
you will be able to produce a specimen
at the physician offices so that's then
what happens is they will give you some
supplies including hopefully Kerry Blair
transport media and other other supplies
to collects do at home but you know it's
a bit of a challenge you have to collect
it you have to bring it back in the lap
back to our lab and our outpatient
centers and drop it off and I would
definitely say that the transport
specimens were highly variable from you
know in correct transport can transport
media and sent directly to the lab to a
stool that's been sitting in a container
on the dashboard your car for three days
and I are trying to send it off so you
can understand why maybe I was concerned
about our re old for bacterial culture
when we looked at how many tests we were
doing we were getting about 20 to 25
tests first dual culture per day so we
needed something that would accommodate
that number of specimens we thought it
would be best if you know we could run
an assay that was on an instrument we
already owned many of our samples and
the vast vast majority of our samples
come from adults and children who are
outpatients and they're otherwise
healthy they just you know have acute
gastritis at this point and I was
definitely although I know I said
earlier like I don't like to think about
cost at all um when dealing with
outpatients I do get concerned because I
know that with rising deductible even
even those who have insurance with
rising deductibles are going to have a
big bill at any kind of Hospital any any
kind of clinic visit so I wanted to make
try to keep costs reasonable as possible
by providing them the best diagnostic
tools
so we ended up going with the BB max
basic enteric bacteria panel and this is
a four target assay that would for
Salmonella Shigella Campylobacter and
sugar toxin producing organisms so why
did we pick BB max well first of all
you'll notice that all five of the
bacterial and the sugar toxin targets
are all reimbursable so I wasn't so I'm
not so worried about the variability of
you know what decisions might come out
on what's going to be reimbursed and
what's not going to be reimbursed with
that mix there so I felt like that was
pretty solid rim on the reimbursement
front
we already have three BB max instruments
in our laboratory we also run the Mrs a
nasal colonization and the vaginal panel
assays so this runs on an instrument we
have in the lab and we have the capacity
to run in the space and time four more
runs per day and then we have a really
close relationships with the infectious
disease and GI subspecialty teams at our
Hospital and so they will really bring
to light anyone you know any patients
who need additional testing beyond like
your bacterial on targets or you know
you're over in parasite if someone same
need was immunocompromised and they were
worried about some of the viral targets
they would let us know and we can range
send out testing and these occasions are
pretty rare so we didn't feel we needed
it on every patient
so how do we validate this target or
this this assay we ran 500 specimens
last summer these were physician ordered
dual cultures and we just ran in the
background the samples and we'd run them
once if the specimen got an
indeterminate result then we would
retest it once more so our testing
breakdown is we had 50 positives and 450
negatives we specifically chose summer
because that's when we tend to have a
higher number of interred pathogens but
still our numbers are not that high
after the first run we had eight samples
that were indeterminate and so we reran
those 8 samples and upon repeat they all
had valid results
and what we ended up finding is that
when you compare culture which is in
blue and PCR which is in grey for the
three bacterial targets on the BB max
assay and the y-axis is number of
positive specimens you can see we had a
slight increase in Salmonella we have a
hundred percent increase in Shigella
that we identified by PCR and a
significant increase in Campylobacter as
well so for all targets piece as
expected you know based on the
literature we found that PCR achieved
more positive targets and culture you
know the increase was small for some of
these targets but also we only had 50
positives overall and most of them were
court agreed with our bacterial culture
so we have one extra Salmonella two
extra Shigella which like I said we only
had two bye-bye cultures we have four
five PCR and then Campylobacter is where
we saw a significant increase as well
okay sheikha toxin result is something
that I think was a benefit to our lab
over previous testing so we previously
did analyze immunoassay but only upon
physician request we did not do it on
every stool and we had almost no
requests so it's very rare for us to
perform testing also we know that the
sugar toxin itself can be pretty labile
and so I'm always worried about specimen
transport about collection things like
that wonder how sensitive our assay
really was um so we had four positive
sugar toxin specimens and our validation
set we repeated all four and they did
repeat as positive on a second time none
of the physicians remember we were doing
these on physician ordered testing and
this was kind of in the background
though the physicians had actually
ordered sugar toxin testing it wasn't
really suspected by the physician um but
on the other hand I say we identified
all these all these
unknown sugar sugar toxin positive
specimens when we did chart review
really in most cases it did not
correlate with suga toxin producing
disease and I suspect that the PCR is so
sensitive you can detect really low
levels of sugar toxin that may be either
transient or produced by you know
potentially produced in low levels by
bacterial colonies in the GI tract so I
think there will be that's an area where
I think the sensitivity of PCR may be
detecting subclinical disease but I
think there will be more to come on the
research front there
so we knew that there were some bacteria
that we would miss by transitioning to
the BB max enteric panel and those
included Vibrio pleasin Monas and Aaron
bonus that were previously detected in
bacterial culture at our lab these were
not nonzero number it's not high numbers
but remember overall we only had 50
positive so these 12 organisms represent
about a quarter of all of our positive
specimens and so we thought it was
important to continue to test for them
so our solution was to combine the PCR
assay with a culture method and we did
this by coupling the BB max enteric
panel with and what we call minute
minimal culture because remember a
traditional culture as all the different
media's and all that well this is just
one blood plate five percent sheeps
blood plate where we're going to look
for oxidase positive organism so what we
do is we inoculate the blood plate after
16 hours of incubation we perform the
oxley sweep and that should allow us to
identify debris oak leaves elonis and
arrow Monas species and you know if we
for us oxidase sweep is positive we will
go on from there and try to isolate the
bacteria if it's negative we will final
it as these oxidase positive organisms
are not detected and so when we combine
our culture plus PCR meth hybrid method
you can see that culture alone would I
would have identified 51 of these
pathogens PCR alone 50 but when you
combine them 62 percent or 62 pathogenic
organisms or toxin producing bacteria
were identified so that that for us was
a 21 percent increase over culture alone
and a 25 percent increase over PCR alone
so this definitely chief our goal of
increasing the sensitivity of pathogen
detection it's a little bit of an
unusual I would say assay
so how did that actually fit with our
workflow so what we do is when a
specimen rise in the lab we plate that
5% sheep's flood auger using Orchestra
total lab automation system and like I
said 16 hours of incubation it will
indicate it's ready for sleep oxidase
testing and then our BB Max and charact
analyst batch dailies we run it every
morning once daily and then the two
areas are resulted separately but into
one report and we wanted to know we we
knew that individually since the
majority of our specimens are negative
for era mona squeezy aloneness and
Vibrio species we knew that in 16 hours
or somewhere in the ballpark of that we
would be able to final the culture
portion as negative and if we're running
the BB max daily once daily with her
around time once a specimens in the lab
should not be more than 20 then around
24 hours but we wanted to check and see
really what was our turnaround time for
results reporting first I just want to
mention one thing is we were concerned
that when we had positive specimens
because we do try to recover the isolate
that that we would have a delay because
we weren't initially setting up all the
different screening media so what what
we do our procedure is when we have a
positive TCR results for Salmonella or
Shigella what we will do is plate the
specimen at that point to have 10
enteric agar and if it's for sugar toxin
we play to sorbitol macconkey agar for
isolation of sugar toxin producing new
coli but again how much time does it
take are we delaying our results by
setting these trying to isolate the
bacteria after it's already been in our
lab for a period of time so we wanted to
check on both on both positive and
negative specimens so
what you can see here is on the x-axis
we have specimens that are negative for
bacterial pathogens in the middle our
pathogens are positive but do not
require susceptibility testing that
would be like our camp live actor just
your molecular result and you're done
and then on the right hand side positive
requiring susceptibility test you know
call isolate isolate isolation or
pathogen isolation and then
susceptibility testing and what you can
see here is number of hours is on the
y-axis the hybrid method is in blue and
the bacterial culture is in gray you can
see that we have reduced our hour time
that we're reporting our negative by
twenty two point four hours so that's
nearly one full day we were going we
were reporting out almost that fifty
hours and now we're down to about twenty
seven hours so just over one full day
from the time the specimens hit our
laboratory now and it's exactly the same
as you would expect for positive results
which Campylobacter we don't need to do
susceptible where we do not routinely
isolate and perform susceptibility
testing you can you can see they're very
similar and what is really interesting
is that even though we do not set up all
of our selective media if we just wait
until we get a Salmonella or Shigella by
our molecular assay and then try to
isolate the organism really that did not
change our turnaround time it's the same
as it would have been if we had set up
all that media in the in the first place
and I had a few questions about that you
know how could that how could that be
really be true but what's interesting is
if you want to know what you're looking
for it's much easier to identify it and
also because of all all of our plate
reading happens on first shift anytime
on you know you're going to start the
isolated bacteria and perform
susceptibility testing it is going to
take
multiple days and so eventually
everything kind of gets synced up on for
shift so definitely we saw a huge
benefit to our hybrid PCR Plus culture
method including higher sensitivity of
pathogen detection by 21 to 24 percent
compared to either culture alone or the
beauty mask impaired panel alone we
found that our turnaround time for
putting out results to our physicians
decreased by more than 20 hours for all
of our negative specimens which remember
with 450 out of the 500 we tested and
for those that were positive by the PCR
panel but did not require susceptibility
testing and we are pleased to find that
there's no difference and no delay in
turnaround time for positive results
requiring organism isolation and
susceptibility testing the other thing
we found is because we are using this
for small for target panel it provided
us highly sensitive rapid detection of
bacterial TI pathogens for a 1/4 to 1/3
the cost of other very large multiplex
panels obviously there are some
limitations as well in addition to
bacteria these large multiplex panels do
include viral and parasitic targets and
for patients that need that it can be
cost-saving to bundle them all into one
comprehensive and rapid identification
system it just depends on your patient
population and so I wouldn't say that
multiplex panels are never
cost-effective but in our patient of
otherwise healthy individuals a small
panel I think was definitely the way to
go for us now if you I talk today about
the beauty max enteric bacterial panel
which has Salmonella Shigella
Campylobacter and shigga toxins they
also do have an extended panel that in
additions that includes two of the
organisms weird
by testing for by culture please see
bonus shigga Louise and Vibrio species
as well as you're sitting at inter
oolitic ax and I will I definitely think
that your Sania and Terra lytic ax is
the is one of the only bacterial
pathogens that were really not covering
well for these days we'd still we're
very small pediatric population and we
do work with our physicians to let them
know if they suspect that they need to
order it specifically and then we'll set
up additional media but in our
population we just we get maybe one
every few years so we didn't feel like
we we really needed to go the extended
in territorial panel just for that
situation if you are interested
depending on your population you need to
cover parasitic or viral panels or
Clostridium difficile and those panels
are also available for BD you can you
can see there and so they have those
options available for you depending on
your patient population so with that I
just want to say again great thanks to
BD for asking me to speak today and I'm
going to pass it over to Christy for the
question and answer session and I can't
wait to hear all your comments so thank
you so much
thank you again dr. Mecca vania for your
presentation yes it is time for our live
Q&A portion of our webinar now if you
have a question you would like to ask
dr. bevel vania please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we
will answer as many questions as we have
time for ok let's get started
first question what response have you
received from your doctors with a faster
result hi thank you so much for joining
us today so I haven't received a ton of
feedback we've been live with this since
March of this year so maybe about five
or six months on you know when I talk to
people and rolled it out they were very
excited but I haven't unfortunately you
know in microbiology we don't always get
the calls about how amazing all our
testing is so um you know over overall
the few people have talked to me I've
been excited about the turnaround time
um but you know a lot of people I think
in micro we spend so much time in the
lab we know the turnaround time to
almost every test we have where I think
for a lot of physicians the results
seemed to randomly pop up so they're
very excited to have the faster
turnaround time but I'm not sure if you
queried them all if they could tell you
what the normal turnaround time for a
chanela
or a salmonella would have been
now what media is used to culture these
organisms so for our new new hybrid
method we use one five percent sheep
blood agar plate only that's the only
media we use if we get a positive result
on our molecular assay say it's a
Salmonella or Shigella then we'll put it
on a Hecht own enteric agar just to look
for that particular organism
thank you dr. Mel macadamia how will you
enhance this workflow
moving forward and how do you adopt
something like this for other syndrome
areas and what syndrome areas would you
go to outside of stool testing huh those
are a lot of great questions that I you
know I think as a microbiologist we
spend a lot of time thinking about how
we can optimize workflow in all the
areas of our lab so right now I think
this we're pretty happy with what we
have right now the next area we are kind
of looking at to optimize as our open
parasite testing and I say that because
we are a low incidence center I would
say less than 1% positivity rate and
that includes non-pathogenic you know
parasites as well so rare that we get
much and when we do it's the same things
over and over we get a lot of Giardia we
get blastocyst as hominis things like
that so we have two old with molecular
testing for parasitology because our
over in parasite it examination we do
traditional methods it's just so
laborious and so that's something we're
kind of looking at but we also know that
we test too much we have a high volume
and a lot of that might you know we need
some stewardship around who gets tested
for / and parasites it's not just part
of stool testing you need to have
specific risks risk factors or travel
history things like that so we're going
to address the stewardship portion in
them
actually move that to either PCR or
maybe some kind of rapid antigen
followed by PCR would probably be where
we're leaning but I'm always looking to
do more research and see which methods
could work best for us
now what do you mean by oxidase sweet
and what is the sweet meat okay so this
is something that we've done in a
microbiology lab for a long time we're
not going you know in a stool culture
there are tons of enteric flora that is
there and we are not going to you know
pick out every one and test them so what
we do is we plate the media and we did
this even as part of our routine
traditional culture on your blood your
blood agar plate you just basically you
take you know a q-tip or a swab through
just drag it through that first quadrant
and then you're going to use some of
your oxidase reagent to determine if
oxidase positive organisms are in there
so traditionally you know all your intro
bacteria a CA or intra back to reality's
now is oxidase negative and so that
wouldn't interfere with the assay but if
you have something that's oxidase
positive then you should figure out if
you do have error monas please the
ammonius or Vibrio species and and those
are causative agents of gastroenteritis
thank you we have so many great
questions coming in and we have time for
just a few more but I want to remind our
audience that those questions we are
unable to answer today dr. Michael Vania
will answer it will be answering them
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration okay alright
next one would you put O&P testing in on
a molecular platform oh so well this is
one that you know I kind of talked about
a little bit before we're definitely
thinking about it we do not use that
method currently but many I guess many
parasite molecular testing options are
either available just recently or will
becoming available in the near future
and some of some of those are more
limited to just a handful of target some
are more comprehensive so that's another
area where I think you really need to
look at what are you getting out of your
stool cultures what pathogens are you
identifying and are the targets on each
individual panel are those going to
cover you know a large percentage of
what you're using again a little bit
concerned about the cost because most of
our open parasite testing does come from
outpatients and even though a
traditional over in parasite examination
is very labor-intensive for the lab it's
not that expensive for the patients so
molecular will likely be more expensive
but again if it could be more sensitive
and then also help with our workflow
save our text a lot of time and allow us
to kind of restructure our parasitology
bench on you know it's something we're
definitely looking into
thank you let's go with this one do you
enriched the stool samples and if so how
long so for this essay we do not enrich
the stool samples we use direct or that
PCR si is direct on stool and then our
our 5% she blog blood auger plate that
setup is also direct on stool we don't
use gram-negative breath or anything
like that when we do isolate or do have
a molecular positive for sugar toxin we
will put the stool in gram-negative
broth and then we incubate it overnight
to see if you know there's a greater
chance that we can recover that pathogen
but but otherwise we plate directly
dr. McElveen eeeh we have an attendee
who is wondering why you don't report a
preliminary report for the PCR portion
of the test well we don't necessarily
they are they are finals separately
though so although it's not a
preliminary report each both the culture
portion and the PCR portion the order
one test but then in our once it hits
our the physician orders one test but
then it actually leads to two kind of
testing orders in our lab one for the
culture portion and one for the PCR so
whichever one is finished first will pop
up and then followed by the second one
and then whoever puts in the second
result whether it's the culture or the
PCR they will final the report once it
has both components present so you you
will get a prelim report of one or the
other but it just depends on the time of
day because we do our PCR testing in the
morning every day once daily and then
you know the culture portion to get
finals anytime it's reached its
incubation period so that's really going
to be more dependent on what time the
specimen came in so you might get your
your oxidase sweet- oxidase sweep and
your negative result on the culture
portion even before molecular
or dr. Mikkel Vania let's wrap with this
final question could you please repeat
what were the limitations of this method
so I think the main limitation of this
method for me is that I know you're
Sania enter Lolita is something that I
am NOT going to identify unless a
physician says specifically that they
are you know concerned about this
pathogen based on the patient history
and then if they put that in the test
comment or if they email me or call the
lab then we'll set up additional media
to make sure we look more closely for
that organism this is a limitation of
what we're doing but I also think that
are we do not have a large pediatric
population here it's you know fairly
small and so for that reason you know
we've communicated this limitation to
providers and feel pretty pretty
comfortable but it is something you know
I feel like it's the only whole and
otherwise it's a pretty comprehensive
screen for bacterial GI pathogens
thank you again dr. Mikkel Vania now
before we go I would like to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions there are a
handful of questions that we were unable
to answer today so those questions and
those questions that are submitted
during the on-demand period dr. Michael
Vania will be answering them via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration I would like to
thank again dr. Aaron macadamia for her
time today and her important research it
also like to thank lab Rhodes and our
sponsor Biddy for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand and lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event the
survey will now pop up on your screen
and your participation is appreciated
your answers help improve our webinar
program thank you for joining us and we
hope to see you again soon